القط بات يحرس اللبن فقرار تخويل وزير
الماليه المتطرف سبوت ريتش بان يصبح بديلا
عن المستوى السياسي في قرار البناء
الاستيطاني منفردا يعني بان البناء سيصبح
سريعا بدون قدره على وقفه او ابطائه فقد
كان وزير الدفاع يوقع على اربع مراحل
للبناء في المستوطنات بموجب قرار حكوميا
مسبق فيما سيصبح سبوتريتش مخولا بان يوقع
مرتين فقط على مرحلتي التخطيط والتسويق
بدون الرجوع للحكومه وهو مستوطن يسكن في
احدى مستوطنات الضفه الغربيه المحتله
تدليل هذه العقبات او الاجراءات
البروقراطيه له ابعاد سياسيه وقانونيه نحن
نتحدث عن ضم فعلي الان للضفه اصبح
سموتريتش وهو وزير مستوطن ووزير الاستيطان
هو المسؤول عن الاقرار هذه المشاريع وايضا
كونه مستوى السياسي وليس مستوى امني هذا
يعني انه الصفه المؤقته والعسكريه لل
انتفت عمليا حرق المراحل في مشاريع البناء
الاستيطاني سيسرع عمليات البناء على نحو
دراماتيكي ويبدو خطوه اخرى تجاه الضم
الاسرائيلي الزاحف للمناطق المصنفه جيم
والتي تشكل ثلاثه ارباع الضفه وتسيطر
عليها اسرائيل امنيا ومدنيا ايضا وتقع
فيها كل المستوطنات
في نهايه المطاف هذه الخطوات ستؤدي الى
تقويد اتفاقيات اوسلو ومنع امكانيه التوصل
الى حل سياسي مع الفلسطينيين وستسرع
محاولات العمل على ضم مناطق جيم لاسرائيل
اليه البناء الجديده تزيل الكوابح من امام
البناء الاستيطاني وتغضب الفلسطينيين
وتزعج الامريكيين وقد تخضع الاختبار عمليا
قريب حيث تخطط اسرائيل لاقرار بناء اكثر
من 4500 وحده استيطانيه جديده الاسبوع
المقبل
الحلم الوردي للمستوطنين يبدو قريبا
بتسليم الوزير الاسرائيلي المتطرف سموتريج
مفاتيح البناء في المستوطنات مع تكثيف هدم
المنازل العربيه بحيث تضيق خارطه الواقع
امام قيام دوله للفلسطينيين في مقابل
ازدهار دوله المستوطنين زياد حلبي العربيه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات